brand why did you request I mean that
might be a top two favorite like she's
got so many hits Reba like why haven't I
earned females like one of my favorite
jams to sing why did you pick it though
I picked it because my mom is my best
friend Linda and she's completely
selfless she volunteers thousands of
hours in her community and she was
diagnosed with terminal breast cancer
and given two years and that was four
years ago so she's still offense you
know she's raised us kids and I promised
her that when she beats it we're gonna
take her to see Reba and that is the
goal of ours but she's really sick so
having you seeing it as an excess thing
because we absolutely love you and thank
you so much given two years and it's
been four yes she's one hell of a
fighter yes she absolutely is that's a
beautiful thing for years they gave her
too she's she got this yeah
[Applause]
yeah well tell me a little bit more
about your mom though like why she's
such a big Reba fan um she's just always
raised this on country music and growing
up in the car at home she's always
played Reba for us so we've just always
grown up with music and she's huge on
country so I'm huge on country huge on
Kelly and so um yeah just be singing it
was really big for her okay well I love
your mom she's awesome so what's your
mom like is she fun like you
oh she's tons of fun I could tell you
stories but it probably not appropriate
we've got the biggest and perfect yes
and we have get-togethers at the house
and she hosts all the holidays and all
the parties and she's amazing my she's
so much fun even even though she's sick
she and makes sure that she's the life
of the party as best as she can be and
she still does everything for everybody
else even though she's going through
what she's going through everybody else
comes first thing you know to Reba but I
think your mom deserves the best so
please welcome country legend Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
you are an innovation to me my sisters
my brother my mom I mean my mom
listening to music I bless her spirits
I mean her license even says survivor
after your serene and we just we love
you so thank you so much for being that
for alright so since your mom isn't well
enough to join us today we're going to
talk to her at home okay all right so
look in the camera and let's give it's
what your mom is leaving out Linda Linda
Linda we have 70 here they might want to
say something to you hey Linda I'm Reba
McEntire and I just want to tell you
that my thoughts my prayers go out to
you and hang in there girl I know you're
tough you can beat this sucker let's see
okay so for this is so weird cuz you you
know when your friends and family was
told mean you doesn't want your show
it's awkward I ended up marry your old
all the sudden and and you got stuck
with me more thank goodness we've had I
always have my little moments with you
because I know we're friends and we're
family but you're always like that hero
to me like especially musically like
you're just Abby's like a pioneer for
women like it's insane I think what's
amazing about your career is you're a
businesswoman you've conquered Broadway
you've conquered TV you've conquered
movies animated film I mean you've done
everything you could possibly want to do
so like my question is what is the next
mountain because you've done you've
already mastered everything well have
mastered or conquered anything I've just
gotten to participate people were nice
enough to let me be a part of I tell you
what I'd really love to do okay I want
to do an authentic Western movie or a
television show a Western
I love westerns well there's so many
avenues now
yeah like amaz all the things everywhere
we can make this happen
Kelly Clarkson says so right there
[Applause]
I would love and this is only because
when I first heard you it was like a lot
of like Oklahoma kind of Texas swing
kind of style I would love an old school
record like an old school country like I
think that would be amazing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's the best kind of country music
that I feel like separates it from other
genres and it doesn't blur the lines of
pop or anything it's like that authentic
just storytelling of like she thinks his
name is John or Anne still or just all
those songs are so meaningful and I've
changed people's lives along with
Brienne like oh by the way that's my
middle name I don't I just remember that
um my husband's making fun of me back
there and you know it well as promised I
found some old photos of you are you boy
oh gosh how old are you there I think
second grade oh my god you're adorable
look at that you had that big ol hair
going even then you were like y'all
ain't ready for my hair okay two things
about three things about that I've got
the reins in the wrong hand that is my
brother Pike's calf Ropin horse he
wasn't working too good for Pike so Pike
said I could run barrels on him and I am
rocking the plaid pants yes you are yes
you are man fashion icon be our
okay next oh that day Kelly I want a car
for six months what I would have won a
Ford Torino car for six months and all
you had to do is fill out your little
questionnaire thing and then that is the
Kiowa cowboy high school band right
there
oh my you see the guy on the right Roger
wheels he he is said the band leader for
Alan Jackson oh no and then Suzy's in
the middle and Paik on the left very
Rayburn and Kelly Ron your whole family
sings that's what I find I know that and
I know a lot of people do know that but
it's insane like I'm talking like
everyone seems like well like it's crazy
well daddy I somebody asked daddy one
time said Clark do you do you play he
said I used to play on the linoleum okay
next okay oh my gosh oh that's why Nona
in Trisha yeah Bruce hint cute look at
her hair you are so cute look at all
y'all are so cute when was that I don't
know where all your records oh my god
this is what I'm talking about see this
is 90s country right here like all these
women representing right now and like
they don't play women now hardly on
country what's wrong with y'all now I
know next oh that was for the duets
album and while you came in sing with me
it was so magical it's so funny because
member we actually recorded a different
song first uh-huh and then we ended it
in Crossroads and then we ended up doing
because of you and it was such a magical
moment Kelly we look so young I know I
still look don't you tell shudder I was
here Kennedy the Kennedy Center Honors
thank you for coming and singing I will
do anything for you ever thank you very
much
I generally don't get nervous but I'll
tell you what I'm about peed my pants at
that one I was right I was nervous
oh okay next yeah yeah okay ma'am well
is this in Vegas huh
that's in Vegas oh my gosh next okay bad
about myself oh this is awesome what's
this oh that's what I was Ben and no my
40th anniversary have been in the Grand
Ole Opry there's Vince Gill
Dolly Parton Carrie Underwood and you're
actually reuniting with dolly and Carrie
yes
dolly Carrie and I we are going to be
co-hosting the CMA Awards this year
[Applause]
thank you I'm thrilled it at the back we
need a legend subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going